oh we are live hello
good afternoon wherever the hell you are
in the world and welcome to soundtrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel live
what's good hey everybody how are you
doing we're good
listening you sound like you're in a
cathedral but we're gonna just we're
just gonna crack on
um however you know try not to get too
distracted by that but hey let's run the
run the intro
[Music]
such as music
yeah it just ends though all of a sudden
but anyway I thought we would do a video
and I thought we'd come on and have a
bit of a chat stormy about sort of the
state of sci-fi
um I did a video yesterday this caused a
lot of controversy
um
talked about Bloody woke again
um so
[Music]
I just wanted to have a chat about what
we think
is going on in science fiction at the
moment is it strong have we got a lot of
stuff coming and to that end we had a
look at a list of IMDb shows it's
supposed to be coming in the next 12
months or so and we'll go through them
but before we get into that
Star Trek
right so let's talk about Star Trek
card season three brilliant
um we really enjoyed it
um yeah Kevin McCabe you shouldn't Jay
yeah I know I know I have opinions and I
shouldn't share them but
um I've got politically I think I get a
little bit political but there was a
point to it it was about Stargate and
will Amazon ruined Stargates there was a
point to it but I did get a bit ranty
but I'll try not to
um
so Star Trek we're coming up
Star Trek Legacy maybe section 31 yeah
it looks like and
um Star Trek 90210 is happening so
um what do we what do we think
we have used the term Star Trek 90210 I
don't even know what the real title is
anymore
I forget but that's actually that
actually um trended on Twitter at one
point and I'm like I don't think I
started that I think you may have
um
well I think uh Star Trek is uh
I mean I'm looking forward to all of
them you know it's just more track the
better you know I mean some of it may
not be up to Snuff in terms of you know
the hardcore fandom there may be the
Kelvin timeline some people need to see
couch time for
you
but I'm really now I'm really excited
about section 31 but that's going to be
a movie am I correct on that TV movie TV
living I could literally only get to for
about three months so we're getting a TV
movie
it might spin off into something else
where you know she introduces it and if
it goes well you know you know how
cautious Paramount is these days
but uh
I think they you know they're they're
taking a much more cautious approach
instead of just throwing everything up
against the wall and seeing what sticks
which they should have been doing to
begin with I mean
I mean crazy Klingons from Discovery and
it's
you know
special effects makeup was just I do
Wharf he's so good
he really was spot on
um some of those um Klingons from the
first couple of seasons of Picard It
generally looked like it was a wax works
of a Klingon but it had got a bit too
warm
and it all started to sort of melt a
little bit I thought that's what those
look like but
horrible mistake but Alex Goodson
um I think Star Trek's in seconds I
don't think it's too bad
um I think it's got the possibility to
be okay they just need less strike less
Trek
more quality
and we're good
yeah I would agree with that you know um
in this case you know quantity is not
more than quality you know definitely
get the quality up there
you know and uh
but then you know if you do that you get
the same complaints that people had
about uh
Amazon you know with the rings of power
oh they spent all this money where's the
where's the story you know and
um
it's just like his Training Services you
can't win for losing you know no no no I
mean it doesn't matter what what a big
project like that does someone's gonna
hate it that's the world we live in at
the moment with the internet I'm afraid
that um that's why we're here on the
internet
well I tried to balance out we can we
try to put a bit of love back into the
world instead of just some of the hatred
that some people spew
um but um
the
uh
if you try to be clear and balanced
don't we but you know but we have
opinions
and we share those opinions
hence yesterday's video and oh there's
been a lot of comments but um a lot of
likes a few heads but you know
um so a few I looked
that you're the Reverb on yours is
getting worse
well
um but while you're messing around with
the settings
um I want to ask a question to the guys
in the audience at the moment what is
the best streaming service you think for
sci-fi so you can only have one
streaming service which one would you if
you guys throw a few comments in in a
minute we'll have a chat about it but
we'll talk about a few projects that
coming up first
um whatever you did it made no
difference well push on better be live
and not the best quality than not live
at all
yeah it is it's it's difficult for us to
sort of concentrate a little bit but as
I say it's that or we'd have to just go
off so
um we'll do our best so
two shows at the moment I showed the
moment I've just started watching
um I've just started watching Foundation
the first season again because the
seconds forever now I've already watched
it once I'm watching it again
um I suddenly realized that I'm like I'm
not 100 and I understood most of that so
and the second season starting
um David's
that is the best streaming service I
can't argue with that
um very very good answer
um
so yeah the second season's very honest
and very shortly I'm watching Silo also
on Apple three episodes in right
well it's a mystery wrapped up in an
enigma map show with very good acting
um a couple of TV shows that I've that
caught my eye there's something called
Twisted Metal coming which is very much
like a Mad Max type of TV show it's
going to be on peacock
I think it's going to be quite a
light-hearted almost like a comedy sort
of thing but it's um got Anthony Mackey
from um you know from a Marvel and
Marvel
um so that might
um can I send you that list daily is
there anything that jumped out at you
before we sort of go through it well you
know it's
excuse me you know if if you're into
Star Trek
you know paramounts your place if you're
into Star Wars Paramount your is your
place but you know those those are the
channels they're uh kind of
their
their One Singular kind of sci-fi
content unless you want to throw Marvel
into there too
but there's I think there's some more
selections that are better
in terms of sci-fi then uh Paramount or
Disney unless you're devoted to Star
Trek or devoted to whatever the
Skywalker kids were doing you know uh I
know I pitched this channel a lot and
I'm just going to pitch it again is
Pluto TV
yeah Pluto TV it's free you just go to
pluto.tv I think it is
uh they've got a Channel full of just
nothing but Walking Dead
now you can't go and you can't pick your
episode it's kind of it's just it's just
a regular channel where you're you're
served whatever they're playing
there's two channels of Star Trek
just Pluto don't have to pay for that
there's a whole Channel devoted to just
classic Doctor Who
24 7 all the time
might be watching yay and
um
they'd also have a channel this is I
think important to the viewers here they
also have a channel that's just 24 7
streaming Stargate now
I think it's a TV show I keep hearing
it's a TV show sounds interesting tell
me more yeah yeah well this morning this
morning they were doing
um
they were showing episodes of Atlantis
and then episodes of uh
it's um
no it was uh sg10 sg1 sg1 and
um and but and it's just all that I mean
there's plenty of there's plenty of
content but we just want to watch it you
really don't want to pay for it yeah
that's always a good alternative they
also have a streaming Channel devoted
just to sci-fi it was similar to the
good old days of the Sci-Fi channel
before they introduced wrestling
um I mean this morning they were doing
uh RoboCop the series they were playing
adults I didn't hate that
yeah
it was all right it wandered into the
second season but I
I think there's a second season but I I
certainly seem to remember quite like in
Robocop it's just that they made it for
a network if RoboCop TV series came
along now and they did for streaming
they're allowed to do like RoboCop oh
freaking awesome
[Music]
actually they should do that MGM plus
should be listening they're doing a
movie maybe they should spin that off
into a series so exactly cool but for a
streaming service actually like to blow
people's arms off yeah where they have
to like all be fluffing oh
exactly you know and and Pluto also has
you know three or four channels of
horror in news and everything else but
um it's free and it's got you know stuff
that our our fans you know the viewers
of this channel really love you know
Star Trek Star Wars Star Trek and
specifically uh
um Stargate
uh but I I really Netflix and Hulu is
just so hit and miss
yeah you know um Netflix has got a lot
of I mean there's one show that's coming
on Netflix soon called Black Knight that
on the surface looks really cool but
actually I believe it's Korean but I
have to double check
um Netflix is spending a load of money
on basically Korean television I think
they're gonna spend about three billion
quid or something in the next couple of
years after the success of that show
that I didn't watch that everybody
watched with them
um
um but you know and they had that
Chinese movie a couple years ago about
the wandering Earth sort of thing and
there's there's but there's been a lot
of money in that but I can't I can't
watch it I can't watch a TV show I have
to read
nice
and that really is beautifully made but
it looks
yeah
um it's about a um like a this like
delivery driver in a post-apocalyptic
world's a bit mad Maxi again maybe but
from there let's go
um we've got a couple of TV shows in the
next 12 months or so that are based on
Computing games that are sci-fi coming
along
um Fallout is going to be on Amazon God
of War is going to be an Amazon
um
is that who is that is that a who's the
main actress Living God of War
I don't think we know yet because it's
still in development I don't think
they've started casting just yet they're
hoping to get Chris well the last room I
heard was a Chris judge's favorite he
does the voice for the guy I have to be
careful now because I always mix up God
of War
and the other one that's also being made
now I'm not a big gamer as you can tell
which I want to say is goddess of
something
I'm so useless I remember things and
lives
um
who's doing it and that's the
board game one somebody in the audience
come on quick
um Henry Cavill new show
Warhammer Warhammer sorry
yeah that's yeah no not yeah God of War
oh I think all three of them are going
to be on Amazon actually well
um
Halo's coming out with this season I
think
and Halo
I mean I actually like the TV show more
than I like the video game
yeah it's at the middle of the Season
dipped for me but then it it ended it
started really strong and ended quite
strong but everything in the middle is a
bit
the second half
what they should have done was a bit of
a Mandalorian there and just got
somebody to do the voice and then you
know I just keep his helmet on every
time he's taking his helmet I feel like
oh it's like where RoboCop takes his
Helm off you know it's just like um
a while to figure out where I'd seen
that guy before and he was like the bad
cop on Orange Is the New Black
yeah
it was like I think I might have even
sat next to my um my mom I'm like
halfway through like oh dear God
not at all
yeah
um but I'll tell you what there's some
big projects coming up on Disney in the
next couple of years because they're
throwing their way behind the alien
franchise and we're going to couple a TV
series but we are getting the alien TV
series it's it's already been produced
it's in post-production we're going to
begin the end of this year really next
year
um and it is supposed to be a grown-up
it's not the watered-down network
version of the show it's going to be an
Alien series
and I think we've also got the Weyland
TV series which is going to be maybe
next week
for those those are now is the Alien
series is it like um like during the
Prometheus era or is it in the uh
in the uh
it's gonna be actually contemporary so
it's something around our time I believe
and but they are keeping their cards
really close to their chest on this one
I've heard two or three different
versions of this story and but one is
that it's going to be it's actually
going to be the earliest thing we've
seen
so it'll be pre-riply pre everything but
it'll be and I've even heard it might be
contemporary to our our timeline Now
sort of thing
um so that would be interesting but
obviously Wayland will be a little bit
in the future but not much but
apparently they're gonna they are gonna
blend into each other
I'm just wondering if any of us based on
Alien versus Predator you know in the
Mayan temple
remember that that movie I'm just one
because that was definitely contemporary
um yeah yes that was yep so the uh what
AVP it was contemporary yeah
it could fall on from that maybe yeah
that would be that would be interesting
actually so
um
but I think that's going to be really
interesting
um obviously you've got the God of War
we've got a couple of like
Apple TV project hello the next couple
of years or next 12 months or so
um something called Dark Matter not the
dark matter we've had previously it's a
completely new dark matter starring
Jennifer Connelly and Joel Edgerton it's
about it's an alternative reality thing
that this guy here and his name gets
kidnapped by the alternative version of
himself and then all all hell breaks
loose is lots of fun but Jennifer
Connelly Joel Edgerton big actors oh
hell yeah
uh who else we got some like Spectrum TV
we've got something called constellation
it's only in very early development at
the moment but it's a a woman comes back
from a space flight and all her life's
different and she's got to like fix
though that problem
um the one thing I was excited by though
on that list that actually Apple TV are
currently developing is based on the
Metropolis um fit slangs novel
fancy
that is going to be expensive to make
Jesus bringing that to life I think
that's gonna be a live action television
series but Apple are really spending a
lot of money
I mean they do spend a lot of money but
you know it's
they get a lot out of it compared to
other streaming services you know they
spent a ton on foundation and c and
uh what's the other one All For All
Mankind there's been a lot of money but
the the stories were so well crafted
you know it's it's the kind of series
why you know once you finish it you'll
oh I'll go back and re-watch that where
there's a lot of stuff in this episode
I've only watched the first episode of
mankind and I think it was Bob actually
that's in in the chat at the moment that
said it's the best show on Apple I'm
sure it was if it wasn't you mate but um
uh so I thought oh I better watch it
then
um and I have to submit the first
episode I watched today oh what's good
so today I watched the first two
episodes of foundation and then I
watched from one kind I'm off this week
um
and then they also did the Tom Hanks uh
movie Finch which I thought was really
good
yeah but I will watch that put it on
your playlist uh then there's this uh Dr
Brain which I think is another Korean
kind of thing
I haven't seen it I understood that it's
popular of course there's lots of things
that are popular that I can't get into
it looks like anybody in the chat
actually have they seen the in things
called invading on Apple TV
it looks great it does look
die mosquito
um I think I missed uh flying around me
and it's probably what's causing all the
internet issues for us is that damn
mozzie
um
but is it have you seen it is it any
good have not seen it have not seen I've
only seen the advertising on I mean I
just got into Silo last week
I don't think everyone came out last
week so that's yeah yeah
two
um
there is one who I find it's not really
sci-fi it's more of a spy paranoia
show it's a rabbit hole
Kiefer Sutherland yes I've seen Robert
holy
um that was a bit tricky for me
I know it's supposed to be trippy but
yeah
um would you call have you seen Citadel
on Amazon
no
give it a try good show
um I think I might I think that's almost
uh it's actually like a spy series
they're based in a um it's like a James
Bond sort of private Supply agency
um it's a bit I think about that movie
the um Golden Circle is the sequel uh
the kingsman sort of thing but the
technology
it's very it's very almost it's really
almost sci-fi um but they spent that's
the Russo brothers that did
um the last couple of uh Avengers movies
they spent a lot of money on that TV
show as well
and it's it shows I mean all the money's
on the page so I think
so there's also announcement this week
in terms of since you brought up spy
agency the last season of Archer
but
but but do we believe it because that
show is oh we're quitting and then they
did this other thing where it's the same
characters but in different situations
there's different situations like
yeah
the 12th season
15.
you might be right because I mean not
like saying I stopped watching it years
ago
um but I just thought I got a bit samey
after a while you know
um but you know I yeah I just think I'm
sorry they're just talking thing about
Johnny Quest being a live action series
you know those um
a potentially a live-action series of a
show that I used to watch when I was a
kid called sports bag Billy right and
there was this was generally apparently
proposed
um I think it was Amazon that actually
had a pitch meeting for about six about
nine months ago something like that
sports bag Billy was a cartoon show back
in the 80s and it was a kid called Billy
who used to pull things out of sports
bag right and it motorboats and all
sorts
somebody pitched a live-action sports
bag Billy and when I saw that I was just
like
yeah of course yeah
why not
do it it'd be enough oh um another show
that Apple are doing that I think you
and and I am quite excited about is the
Time Bandits TV series
um
did that ever get a green light or is
that still expect it's improved
so
um
that's going to be mental I mean that
movie
was borderline insane I mean that was
just like
um bloody I don't know and the Monty
Python head button
um I don't know Summit from by the
Muppets or something you know by Jim
Henson or something it felt like a Jim
Henson movie almost but
um but but yeah
headboarded within the Monty Python
um obviously because it was
um created by I was a gamer
um but anyway
um
I think that would be great but that'll
be trippy as hell but that's again the
sort of show that could only be made in
a streaming service now I think
it could never be done on a um
you know serious you know like on a
network
right
um Time Bandits was in 1981.
I was three
yeah
Terry Gilliam it's uh
he it's just that guy I mean Brazil was
awesome Time Bandits of course was
awesome um
he tried to make a Don Quixote movie
with I think Johnny Depp but the uh it
was a total disaster
and there's actually a movie
um
about the failed production of that
whole thing uh
lost in La Mancha I think is the title
of it
the documentary of the failure of the
movie was much better than the movie
ever profit could be
and um was another one that Terry
Gilliam did that uh
uh the fisher king with Robin Williams
that was awesome that was completely
different to anything he'd ever done
before there's always a marvelous movie
just want to make it ah but I mean
anything with Robin Williams is best
it's just
I miss Robin Williams I've been watching
a lot of videos It's stuff that comedy
stand up you did towards the end of his
life and somebody should have been there
I mean now you now I know what he was
going through it was so obvious yeah
there's some of his standards it was
really heartbreaking for us I was just
literally watching that last week just
broke my heart
um obviously we've got a couple of
spin-off TV shows coming in the next
couple of years
gen v a spin-off from the boys
um the Blade Runner 2099 spinner I am
not quoting from The Voice
that one
um but yeah
um again on Amazon both of those
projects are going to be on Amazon
obviously the boys though denvi is going
to be the boys 90210 well it's going to
be teenagers and it's actually the Gen V
like um like the hospital where they
were actually being made sort of thing
always teenagers and their teenage angst
and but they're superheroes so actually
that I do think has possibilities to be
very funny
um because you've got teenagers with
superpowers nothing can I've got teenage
boys dear God imagine if one of them
could um just realize my colors sticking
up through everything
um imagine if one of them could fly or
shoot me with laser beams Jesus
I think one of them my one of my Lads
though does have the invisibility power
it doesn't
you know there's that that drafts in um
the second
um God is a Galaxy and he says I've
become invisible moving so slowly that I
am imperceptible to the human eye that's
my that's one of my teenage Sons
go ahead we've got Blade Runner 2099
interested
yes
1949 was crap
well what do we think about the rumors
of another season of Umbrella Academy
seems like yes
well there are rumors you know of course
how valuable are the rumors
but you know it ended very well I mean
it was probably the last season was
probably one of their better ones you
know and then it looked like it ended
but it kind of really didn't the end of
the world I'm not trying to get way too
many spoilers
of course that of course that's the
ending that's that's the last episode of
any uh series of Umbrella Academy it's
the end of the damn world
well yeah I remember that that was
that's pretty much how the series start
as well
um I love the Umbrella Academy I stopped
watching it in the second season and I
came back for the last season so the
third is that three seasons I think
um and I came back into it and I loved
the last season that mozzie didn't die
I've seen it again
could be
interesting
um talking about spin-offs is going to
be a stranger things spin off
um there's going to be another Game of
Thrones it's been off 12 10 000 ships
um there's very little imagination
I think I got it okay
are you sure
it's very it feels like there's still a
lot of spin-off sequels is that a bad
thing
nah as long as they're good I mean you
know
look at the Star Wars you know first we
you know we got the um the the nine main
movies then there's you know bad batch
which is amazing then there's uh little
Jedis
which I understand and it ends
tragically then there's Clone Wars
I mean and then there's all the video
games that patches in little bits and
pieces of the story then there's the
blue billion comic books and novels and
you know all with varying uh levels of
success and sure why not Disney
squeezing every last drop of Star Wars
out of that stone
[Music]
yeah they love it um but being more of a
Trekkie than a Star Wars fan yeah I I
have become absorbed in the novels and
like you said various levels of success
but when something's good you want to
explore it more or a lot of people do
anyway so I get that
um a stranger things obviously been a
cash cow for Netflix
probably's biggest show in the last 10
years yeah yeah it's gonna be a spin-off
of course there will be um whether it's
good or not we'll find out but going
back to Hawkins
yeah talking about remix though here's
one Sci-Fi show I don't think needs
redoing Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy's coming to Hulu
my main problem with that is Hulu
I think if somebody
else now I gotta take my old glasses off
for this
I haven't run up to it I'm a big
[Music]
huge
Adam Douglas Adams fan big huge fan
in college
go get you go get your room Gandalf hat
and you look a bit like him
and this week on Sidetrack we're being
joined by with Karen Gillian to talk
about the uh guns the Galaxy spin-off
so but yeah but the uh Hitchhiker's
Guide
BBC had a TV show it was a series back
in the 80s
um live action and it was awesome
you know it was you know very you know
really really
um by today's standards really rough
computer Graphics but it was awesome you
know the acting was really good the
writing was really good and then um
there was the other live-action movie
that came out some years ago and
oh dear Lord it sucked
yeah right yeah I mean I
I now know why Douglas Adams died early
he just couldn't stomach it he knew what
was coming he's like oh my God no just
know
as we speak
but yeah it's so
I mean it's possible to do it because
BBC did it early on in the 80s
I think it's like a dozen episodes or
whatever but then it was
just this just now
all right now I'm really snarky about
this I get that you know
but just please know
it won't it I think that's got to
particularly with it being Hulu I think
that's got
mess written all over it well we'll see
because there's this time and you never
know but hey yay now
um
do you think I think is that on my list
um oh one one last project before we
talk about the general thing about how
sci-fi is compared to Fantasy and blah
blah blah Ebbs and flows of television
Paramount plus are doing an ion flux TV
series now that was a movie years ago at
least they're on that was actually
really a really good show
um everyone's been like genetically
engineered and there was uh all sorts
going on
um I I think that could be good
but it depends whether they do a kids
show or whether they do a grown-up show
for that
because it needs to be a bit brutal
there was a
back when MTV
played music videos
um
they had they had they had this uh early
uh TV show called liquid television
where they had a lot of anime and 3D
stuff and Ren and Stimpy was one example
but they also had the the original uh
animated uh Aeon Flux and it was really
good I mean it's still japanimation but
it was just really good and um
the uh Charlie's Theron version was also
good but man the thing about the
japanimation version was just
spot on
yeah
it's a businessman you could put
slurry's throw on in literally anything
and I will think it's good Atomic one it
was a really good movie
yeah you do see writing we break the
acting was just amazing Direction was
impeccable loved that movie
other than Mad Max and she was even
great in that to be honest mad though
that was a terrible film
um but I loved hearing it uh yeah but um
she she is no slots at all she's a great
great actor but I mean I was thinking
the reason why I wanted to do this video
really was because I think we've
mentioned it before that really sci-fi
goes through sort of Ebbs and flows like
everything does
um I actually think like rom-coms at the
moment to become fashionable again
they haven't been for years but
obviously we're getting super soon
films and different things can have Ebbs
and flows I think we've got an awful lot
of magic shows coming up coming you know
um I think the success of things like
The Witcher
um and we've got Harry Potter series
coming
um there's a series called
um Magic the Gathering
um Coming which is it's actually got
quite a big star in it and I forgot who
it was then I did write it down oh
Brandon Roth's doing it not quite a big
star almost quite a big star it was
almost a big start and then he kind of
his career
um but you know so there's a lot of
those sort of shows with the shows we've
talked about are we confident that the
you know the next few years of sci-fi is
going to be exciting or are we on a
downward Trend and I think 12 months ago
we felt like
we weren't getting many big sci-fi
projects getting announced and it felt
that
well I mean
just you know what we discussed today I
think we're going to be inundated with
really good Sci-Fi and that's what we're
also going to be inundated with some
crappy too but you know it's um
you know both Disney and Paramount which
we could argue is the two big players in
sci-fi because they have the the
franchises of Star Trek and Star Wars
and Mark all uh Marvel
um
you know and but Apple you know does
because they don't have a lot of uh fare
but what they do is really impactful you
just can't stop watching it I mean
uh when I first saw uh C with Jason
Momoa advertises like really blind
people
having adventures and just how is that
you know but Mamoa sold it he sold
it you know and uh it was I the writing
was good but I'm telling you man uh
momoa's performance sold it for me and
it was just now it's totally believable
you know and uh
so Apple really knows how to craft
sci-fi but they don't go all in like
Paramount has or excuse me or uh Disney
ass well wait till you see my video
tomorrow because it is about Apple and
sci-fi okay
I actually think if you're a really
hardcore sci-fi fan and you want
something that's new
you've got to have apple
um all the other guys said they're
remaking the same things they're
remaking Star Trek they're remaking Star
Wars they're really making there's not
Netflix does a couple of new things
primed as you know a couple of original
things here and there but Apple does
just original things they haven't none
of their big sci-fi shows in the last
few years have been remakes
one they would love to have a big
franchise on Apple hinting yeah video
tomorrow but if you want original sci-fi
based on novels and things normally but
you've got to watch Apple
yeah
they're the only ones doing it so I mean
is an original book by uh Hugh Howey
started out the first
yearbooks I believe yeah yeah yeah yeah
several books
and they really did it well that Apple
does take their time with everything
else doing it right the first time
um
but they're very picky and sometimes I
don't think um
uh Paramount or dizzy Disney or Hulu or
Netflix are all that picky they just say
oh this sounds like a good idea let's
run with it now do you know who we
really haven't mentioned in this in the
show
HBO
I mean typically they're just
repackaging stuff that's already been
the theater or someplace else
you know
yeah I mean they've got some big fine
fantasy projects coming you know they're
really gone in all they've gone you know
all in on the games of thrones I don't
think there's any big
sci-fi stuff anybody guys get into the
comments telling you know anything you
think
um
I think HBO or oh sorry Max I think it's
called this week
um next week will be called something
else but at the moment it's called Max
um sounds like a condom brand
yeah
well here's the thing that for HBO and
in sci-fi is
how this got a second season I'm not
really sure but raised by wolves
I didn't try to watch that
right I liked the premise
I thought the show was terrible
it was boring I mean I got to the I kept
holding it out man I really did I held
out I held out I got to the last episode
and it was just such a WTF like what
what
you know and it was it was just so
scattered man I mean it was just yeah
it was like
Crystal all over the place and I
couldn't follow it and I got bored in
situation of course ordered the second
season they ordered season two
yeah
Derek just mentioned there that um HBO
sorry Max
um
they should call it Max for her pleasure
now that's what that should be the
tagline for the channel
um isn't it 50 50 would be on Max yeah
yeah the CW do have first dibs but
Warner Brothers want it for Max that's
why they think it should go and it will
end up on max if whether it's on CW
first and then it'll be shown on Max
like immediately afterwards it will be
on Max
um but Apple have inquired they would
like um Babylon five if um they would
like to pay for it and buy it and do
everything and that considering Max's
and Warner Brothers Current financial
problems don't be shocked if they get it
so they might go yeah
90 billion dollars in checking
yep I mean
Apple already have a really good working
relationship with Warner Brothers so I
mean Ted lasso is a Brother's production
and they're making Speed Racer for Apple
you know they they already have a really
good worker relationship so I wouldn't I
wouldn't put I would give you good odds
that it could appear on Apple
I wouldn't I wouldn't bet against it
right
um but obviously the CW you've got first
dibs so we'll see
um but yeah
um I'd be interested in that I I
honestly think sci-fi is seeing I think
this thing is pretty strong at the
moment
um I think Picard season three really
picked up for me Star Trek and made me
feel a bit more confident about what's
coming in Star Trek so I was starting to
get a bit worried you know I was like
strange new worlds but I didn't like the
last couple of episodes and I'm thinking
oh God where's this going
um
Picard season one and two were obviously
absolute turds in space
um
and you know I I'm thinking I like the
animated stuff but other than that Star
Trek is going down the Pan
um but no you know Picard season three
gave me some hope
not a massive fan of the Star Wars stuff
but Andor is brilliant
um that was amazing yeah the third
season of Mandalorian
feels like they've run out of ideas a
little bit
um you know so I was thinking I'm not so
sure about this and it seemed to be
there's just loads and loads of fantasy
stuff getting announced
but
hopefully Stargate is about to get
announced yeah
um you know so that would make me I
don't give a crap if anything else gets
canceled to be honest
but then I think science sci-fi has a
good future I think there's some really
really interesting there's a mix there
is there is some there are some remakes
there is some revivals but there's also
some really interesting sounding
original stuff coming as well
um and again most of that's going to be
on Apple by the looks but yep
as long as it's getting made no we'll
watch it eventually and just get apple
for a month binge it turn it off right
so is uh is I keep reading um differing
opinions so for the new uh Stargate is
um Brad right in or is Brad right out
currently out
could be out
well I if you've watched some of these
things if you haven't if you're watching
right now and you haven't signed the
petition that I created last week
signatures already in less than in just
over two days so
that's that's really great
um at the moment right now Brad writer
has not been contacted by MGM at all and
I've had that from the horse's mouth
he's told me himself no contact
UM
my my point of view is that Amazon
don't really want him involved for more
business reasons than anything else but
they never actually liked particularly
like to script in the first place
um I was asked who that was and
apparently was Jennifer salkey who
actually vetoed it and said I I don't
like the way that's going but they could
have worked for Brad on that it's more
business reasons why it's not going to
be Brad because they need a production
company
you know they need somebody that's
actually going to make it so right but
right now it is Brad out but
but
VM Brad Wright has big supporters so if
we can give him a nudge in the right
direction
but anybody that thinks he's going to be
the show runner
or even right episodes is going to be
disappointed because he's not
um a consultant an executive producer
maybe
um and my way of thinking is it's better
with Brad than without
it's just simple as that really
um but for me it's a real brainer
um but I really I talked about another
video about this like the rings of power
problem that Amazon are fearful of now
that YouTube is basically going to hate
this show before it ever gets made and
they're going to share quote they're
going to shout everything out here and
there's going to be so much negativity
and they just want to avoid that they
think one way of avoiding it bring in
Brad
you know
so uh John think that's
um it isn't in the description but if
you go back to not the last video the
one before that actually I think of the
last two videos there's links in the
description for for that and it's also
on the Community page so
um it is it is there sir
um but what do you think
is it a no-brainer bringing Brad back
well I think it I think it gives it a
better chance for success
you know it was like it rings of power
would have had a better chance of
success
if if it
um
kind of used you know as backdrop a lot
of the assets from Lord of the Rings
you know
I mean Peter Jackson no slouch
you know his you know even if it's a
cursory involvement I think it still
would have improved
at least the fan reaction
yeah
I think they made mistakes very early on
for the rings of power and one of the
big mistakes was not involved I mean
Pete it turns out the pizza Jackson
couldn't have got involved because of
contracts with Warner Brothers anyway
um apparently that was apparently Amazon
did try and get in touch with him and
then they went very quiet but he
couldn't have done it anyway
um well you know with a quarter billion
dollar budget you could have slipped
Warner Brothers or who or whatever some
cash and it would have suddenly been
okay
I think they were probably already
planning their Rings Lord of the Rings
rival
so oh that's right Lord of the Rings
Revival thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and there's still plenty of stories to
be told from
tokens uh Middle Earth
yeah
they are going to be different stories
so
um I wanna I want the movie to be going
on and in the background you see Frodo
walked past looking miserable carry the
ring something
whatever you know they stop and just
look at him sort of thing and then carry
on whatever the movie's about
um
yeah
um but but yeah uh I think avoiding that
that
negativity on YouTube though is going to
be really important because people and
it turned out you know a lot of people
really hated the show I I found it a
little dull
um I know you loved it
um oh my god let's watch it again
and you're a big token fan so you
actually know the material
um I think there's a lot of people that
hated that didn't really know the
material they'd watch a bunch of YouTube
videos that tore it apart and that's
what they were good you think
but there are people as well they're
genuinely I say I am in that category of
I didn't particularly like it but I
didn't like it because I found it too
slow and I found it a little boring
um and I thought to me that's the that's
the biggest crime a TV show can do a TV
show can have
woken on Cincinnati can I have whatever
I hate all these terms but Mary Sue's or
I can have all that crap
um but if it's boring if I'm watching it
and I'm looking at my phone
that's that's the biggest crime
um and rings of power
it's difficult to get your audience back
but I do think things are power improved
and by the end of it I was I was
actually watching it I think I even said
about about episode five or six I was
like oh bloody that was a good episode
um I just think it didn't for the money
it didn't seem big enough you know some
of the battles you're thinking there's
only like 12 people there
um and things like that that's what it I
don't know but I think
for one they let it out everybody they
were spending on it and they were almost
like proud of it and they shouldn't have
done because that pissed people off
immediately that turned a lot of people
off and then as well I think they were
screwed over by the um Banky Kerry got
the link in the description for the
petition thank you so much please go
sign that and share it with your friends
we need to get loads and loads of shares
we've got 2 000 signatures and all
nearly a thousand shares on the petition
so that is just amazing it'll keep
growing we hit 10 000 I will be buzzing
that would be amazing
um oh sorry I didn't mention that
um
I got distracted by the petitions a lot
of the Rings yeah Wolverines once you
lose your audience it's hard to get it
back yeah yeah and um and I just think
there's too much but yeah so they know
so much they're spending that was a
mistake I think they got screwed over by
the family
um I think there were so many things
they were allowed to talk about and not
talk about to me if I was Amazon and I'm
negotiating that early on
I'm thinking look this is going to cost
us
400 million dollars or something
whatever it was ridiculous money to get
these rights if we're spending that only
we would be able to do whatever we want
and the family they're going you can't
do this you can't do that you can't do
something you can't talk about this
because but they don't own the movie to
certain things there's certain things
illegally they couldn't do and I just
think
it it confused the storyline and gave
way too much ammunition to the people
that were just going to show hey
yeah
you know and um
I mean like I said there's a lot of uh
uh Middle Earth Tales to tell
but it's like
they went around they they left a lot
out and it may probably like you said
he's like well they they didn't get this
sliver of this book and then and they
only got this passage here but without
the middle Pages you know yeah and it
was it was noticeable you know it was
noticeable
but uh before we go there's one other
uh fantasy show I want to talk about
this should be coming up pretty soon and
that's the Wheel of Time
seriously
season two um yeah
I did watch the first season God how
many years ago was it now it was pretty
covered wasn't it the first season
it was a film during covet I think and
came out it's like uh
2000 let me look it up
yeah
um I
wasn't the biggest fan
um not because of all the things that
people throw at it I think it didn't for
Amazon actually when we're talking about
they spent way too much on Lord of the
Rings they didn't quite spend enough on
Wheel of Time I think it places it
didn't quite go far enough and they
could it could have been better but also
I think the right it's quite jerky in
places and I struggled to get through
with it but I've never read the novels
so I do yeah
yeah I'm sorry uh it came out in 2021
2021 yeah
um but yeah I just wonder if I'd have
read the books maybe if I'd have
appreciated it a bit more
I'd like to I'm going to do a series
with you one of the days actually we're
gonna have to talk about sci-fi books
that you've read and then I'll like
watch the equivalent movie or series and
see how they compare because I don't
need
I can read
I choose not to
um I've read the Harry Potter books from
back to back
I can't tell you another book I've ever
read
[Music]
Shakespeare than I've read anything else
because I was made to
um
and I've read the Bible but that was
more to argue with nuns I went to
Catholic school so um
you know so uh but I've never but I do
wonder if Wheel of Time might have
appreciated it more if I'd have read it
so I don't know if you make sense
maybe I mean the books were excellent
just
Robert Jordan excellent I mean he could
tell tell there were all these really
intricate relationships with literally
hundreds of people throughout the the
series and it was just so engaging
and I knew one problem that even if they
you know spent large like they did on uh
rings of power there's no way they can
encapsulate it you know they're trying
to get you know one
one book per season well what is like 14
15 books by the time is all over with I
mean you know Robert Jordan died
and then they had to bring in
Brian Sanderson is that his name to
finish it and he said oh these are this
is more than one but
right so when when the series then it's
based on a book I always think it's a
good idea I like it when TV series and
movies but particularly TV series are
based on books because I always think
about there's the Lost problem you know
then that TV series Lost judge Abrams
started off brilliantly everybody loved
it and then by the end of it you could
realize they didn't have a plan they
didn't know where this was going and
then it was you know very very
successful so they stretched it out or
you get sometimes you get TV series that
there's one season it's a brilliant idea
and then they're quite popular and then
you can just tell again they they
weren't thinking about the second season
they don't know where they're going but
at least if it's based on a book
normally that's why I'm so excited about
Silo this isn't going this is going
somewhere there's a point to these books
this story sort of thing because there's
a book
um but when it's a book that's really
loved in like Wheel of Time
if you well if you were in charge of
Amazon would you be thinking yeah this
is a great opportunity were you thinking
if we mess this up it doesn't matter how
good the show is if it doesn't meet
expectations it's going to be crap it's
going to be unpopular
yeah I mean it's um
there there's in terms of like high
fantasy you know of course there's token
but then there was also uh the sword of
shanara series and uh Wheel of Time
you know it was I look I just looked up
it was 14 books and uh Robert Jordan
died in book 11 knife of dreams and so
the family said well let's just get
Brandon uh Sanderson he'll finish it up
so yeah I can do it in one book and he
comes back and reads all the notes oh
this is going to take three more volumes
really thick
really like uh yes um
like a book 12 was 766 Pages book 13 was
864 pages
Memory of Light the last one book 14 was
912.
huh with the Harry Potter's all you have
to do is you have to just pick a
storyline that goes through those books
and stick with it you can't try to do
the whole thing well you can't do it
justice it's you know it's just you
can't do it so yeah but you know Sanders
and he took the main themes
fleshed them out and he did a wonderful
job they were re I mean he he he did a
great service to the community to the
fans he did a great service to uh Robert
Jordan and but it they turned out
fabulous
um
oh crap well let's see what the TV
series done I will give I will give
Wheel of Time a chance um I've got to
watch it I've got to watch For All
Mankind first
um because like I said watch this
episode
uh the token we're about to lose the
entire audience because David Hewlett is
live on Twitch so everyone's gonna go
um I have invited him he didn't respond
so guys on Twitch a new thing send him a
message tell him I would love to speak
to David Hewlett and I will give money
to charity any charity he wants if he
comes on the show
um one thing I should I should sort of
mention now and the channel just give 10
of his earnings to charity each year
um at each month sorry
um I'm running out of Charities to give
money to so if anybody has ideas or
Charities that they wish that you know
they're hard and you know the YouTube
money from the channel to go to I will
accept
nominations or whatever so um I do that
each month
um I've given to the rspca the Lifeboat
a local charity down there I've
literally I've run out so anybody's got
any ideas
I'd love I'd love to hear it
I'll
actually know I know you're involved in
that and I've never thought of it will
you please drop me a link and yes this
month the central go to books results
never occurred to me I know you do that
too so
30 plus million dollars in Aid to
British and American soldiers serve and
interact in Afghanistan and he forgets
about me
I'm glad I brought it up man I'm glad I
brought it up so yes drop me the link to
the charity that's where it's going this
month but anybody has any other
Charities that really close their heart
please let me know I'm sorry I'm such an
idiot I'm slow I think I might have been
dropped when I was a baby
there are times when I really do
question my own intelligence
brilliant perfect and it's a it's a
really really good charity that's
close to my heart as well so just
quickly before we go I'm just gonna run
the nine Chevrons advert because there's
a big story on there right now so here
we go ninechevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com
there is um obviously there will be a
link to the petition on there as well
because we dropped a story on it today
so
um exclusive news from Sidetrack and
from night chevron.com
um stormy thank you so so much mate I
think we've we can put to bed any
concerns about sci-fi over the next few
years it's insane I think it's still
good yeah as long as you've got Apple TV
if you haven't got Apple TV
you think you're going to watch a lot of
Star Wars or Star Trek
um
TV or you're on a budget Pluto TV
Walking Dead Star Trek Doctor Who and
Stargate
you can't argue with that and watch the
classics
back on the FC actually used to make 22
Episodes or something and could still do
original content every week except for
the occasional filler episode
um but I I was talking to a writer about
the writer strike last three commercial
they're saying look I keep getting
people
demanding you know like 22 they want why
why don't streamers serves to do 22
Episodes and he actually I swear to God
I thought he was gonna Cry he's like no
don't do that I can't do that don't make
me do that again I'm just like what you
want about Mexico because I he used to
work on a quite a big Sci-Fi show
um 15 years ago uh you could probably
guess what that might have been but I
can't I watch anymore
um and you're just saying that was nine
months of my life
shaking rocking in the corner just like
writing constantly said and he would
literally be writing stuff and the the
director would be there with his handout
going come on we gotta Film It come on
certain things like I'm writing and it
would literally be right out the door at
the door and it was just it was the most
stressful thing he's ever done in his
life
and I was like please don't do that
again I can't do it so so um I don't
think they want to go back to that
um but bless him I genuinely thought
he's gonna cry
um but uh thanks Tommy thank you so much
for this live chat we will be doing this
well until you get a proper job where
you can don't have to work Sundays
you're gonna be like we'll do the
midweek show so but hey
so that's true
this uh weekend we are doing a Stargate
episode partly to push the petition talk
about the petition but also I did have a
couple of information about an
interesting couple of bits of
information about San Diego Comic-Con
and we have a couple of other bits of
information to talk about so we're
having our Stargate monthly episode
and other than that
thanks for joining everybody
um sorry about the sound
it's but actually I think it's improved
I don't know what you did with it about
halfway through but it's it's fine now
so well done
thank you it's awesome see you guys
later thank you stormy see you guys
later thanks everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]